some of the most memorable moments in
recent TV history weren't even planned
but we're instead born from inspired
improvised moments between gifted actors
they may have felt too perfectly placed
to be off-the-cuff but here are a few
genuinely unscripted exchanges that took
viewers and producers totally by
surprise and we're not making this one
up on the spots there are definite
spoilers ahead Stormborn smooch Game of
Thrones is a very expensive obsessively
examined show so it makes sense to
assume every moment must be scripted to
the letter however as it turns out
there's some room for flexibility on the
series in the season 7 episode Stormborn
you are a Greyjoy in the Laureus and get
to know each other a little better
before being interrupted by an attack
seems like you don't need a protector
actress Gemma will then who plays Yara
revealed after the episode aired that
the kiss wasn't scripted saying that it
quote just has seemed like something we
should do Moira knows best
many fans were left heartbroken when
Oliver's mother Moira bit the dust on
the CW's arrow
Moira sacrificed her life for her
children and moments before getting a
sword through the chest she pleaded with
her daughter to look away actress
Susannah Thompson later revealed that
plea was actually improvised she came up
with the closure eyes comment as a way
to bridge the gap between Moira telling
Slade to let her children live and her
actual death executive producer Marc
Guggenheim ended up loving the line so
it made the final cuts Poppins improv
happy endings was a joke machine in its
three seasons on ABC with a naturally
hilarious cast it makes sense some of
those jokes will be improvised including
a small but fun moment featuring a Mary
Poppins reference from Jane played by
Eliza coupe why is it so freezing in
here no I just happen to bag to was
referencing her husband played by Damon
Wayans Jr whose cologne attracts pigeons
the actress was surprised to see that
people on Twitter noticed and
appreciated the relatively obscure joke
which is a reference to the feed the
bird scene in the Disney classic feed
the birds
chuckles ooh Berg off on the right foot
Arthur was never a great friend to
Merlin while starring on the characters
namesake BBC One series but the two did
have fun messing with each other on the
show just as the actors did behind the
scenes according to actor Bradley James
the scene in which his Arthur rubs his
foot on Merlin's face in season one
after a sweet bonding conversation was
actually just him messing with actor
Colin Morgan but it ended up making it
into the final cut
James revealed on the DVD commentary
that that was his favorite bits of the
episode but that he didn't do it in
rehearsals cry-baby there were a lot of
heartbreaking moments in Breaking Bad
over the years but one of the biggest
tearjerkers came in Walt's baby daughter
Holly started calling out for her mother
after her father abducted her but that's
not how the scene was planned during the
bathroom scene the little actress saw a
real mother just a few feet away and
ended up calling out to her credit goes
to actor Bryan Cranston for rolling with
it because the moment ended up being an
instant classic fruit of his labor even
if you only watch psych intermittently
you know how important pineapples were
to the show as it turns out the whole
thing started thanks to an improvisation
from psych star James Roday oh should I
slice this up for the road road a was so
enthusiastic about the joke that the
producers felt like he just had to keep
it in and it spiraled out from there one
of the tropical fruits appeared in
almost every episode of the series in
addition to featuring prominently in its
marketing over the years thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]